[Music]
the travel lookout motorcycle RS I need
a new vehicle ASAP
this is an overwatch operation our team
is engaged in a higher form of
patriotism it's not a military operation
the goal is to complete the mission at
any cost we do weak on a beach you're
never gonna do something normal until
you die that's what this job is and not
you you're pretty close besides this is
my Beach feel the sand between my toes
sir
you ever walk in Boise that's my asset
local Special Forces sent him to medical
to see if usually says he is what is
your name Lee neuter are you involved in
acts of espionage yes I have information
that proves my government is planning an
attack on the United States you have no
idea how evil my government is
lovely uh noventa to us that gives you
everything take a drive you're going up
against this country is elite tactical
squads back correct
no one ever enters a war thinking they
were loose but one side is always wrong
don't give you some advice you ready
stop they miss that plane we have fed
they miss that plane they are dead
company
failure is not an option
we get him out we save millions of lives
requesting hand of God coming down
[Music]